Und jetzt?
Wie schaut es jetzt aus, Leute?
Jetzt ist es besser wieder.
Okay. Nice.
Okay. F5.
Jetzt geht es wieder.
Alter, was ist das gewesen?
Ich glaube,
es liegt nicht mal an Vodafone,
sondern einer der Twitch-Server
in Frankfurt ist abgeschissen.
Weil ich habe jetzt einfach den Server gewechselt
und jetzt gibt es keinerlei Lags.
Ich bin von Frankfurt 5
auf Frankfurt 2 Twitch-Server.
Ich glaube, diesmal kann Vodafone
nichts dafür. Ich glaube wirklich, dass der Server von Twitch
verreckt ist gerade.
AWS kaputt.
Oder AWS.
Wieder die richtig krassen Leute zu sagen.
Ja, ich glaube,
Twitch hat wieder Probleme.
Vodafone-Emote wäre nice.
Wir haben irgendwo ein Vodafone-Bild.
Moment, es gibt...
Das ist ja mega.
Da muss ich mal eins hinzufügen. Sekunde.
Da muss ich mal das passende hinzufügen.
Pils Vodafone.
Chat, welches wollen wir
davon hinzufügen?
Ihr könnt es euch aussuchen.
Also ich persönlich finde das hier ja nicht verkehrt.
Aber die zwei sind auch cool.
Das ist auch nice.
Das ist auch cool.
Pils Vodafone-Man.
Das ist ja geil.
Ich glaube,
Pils Vodafone-Man wird es.
Perfekt.
Es läuft bei allen schon wieder.
Okay, wo sind wir?
Wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben?
Wir haben da angefangen,
uns das Video anzuschauen.
Ich spule noch mal ein bisschen zurück,
dass wir das alles mitgekriegt haben.
So, also.
Erstes Mal Mac OS. Komme ich damit zurecht.
Da sind wir stehen geblieben.
Ich will die doch nicht löschen, die Diskette.
Mein Apple-Trauma hat sich dann über die Jahre etwas aufgelöst.
Ich hatte dann irgendwann ein iPad,
was ich sehr ans Herz geschlossen habe.
Und mir sogar irgendwann für diesen Kanal
ein iPhone 13 Pro als immer.
Also wie gesagt, ich habe auch ein iPhone und ein iPad.
Ich mag das Apple-Ökosystem jetzt zwar nicht so extrem,
da ich sage, ich will alles Apple-mäßige haben.
Mir geht das auch regelmäßig auf den Keks.
Aber gerade wenn wieder so der Apple-Way der einzige ist,
der funktioniert, ja.
Aber insgesamt muss ich sagen,
gerade was iPads angeht,
finde ich die schon angenehmer als Android-Tablets.
Und ich habe mich jetzt seit Jahren ans iPhone gewöhnt.
Ich gehe davon aus,
im mobilen Sektor werde ich dem iPhone und dem iPad
da auch treu bleiben.
Aber nicht, dass jemand sagt, ich hätte das nicht ausprobiert.
Ich habe auch Android-Tablets am Start.
Ich denke, man sollte einfach das benutzen,
was sich für den jeweiligen Anwendungszweck gut eignet.
Und gerade was Automatisierung angeht,
ja, und so als Home Assistant-Dashboard im Flur und so was,
da sind Android-Tablets natürlich nice.
... dabei, Videokamera angeschafft.
Ich war davor eher so der Android-Typ,
aber die Videoqualität des iPhones hat mich dann ziemlich schnell überzeugt.
Ja, und jetzt ein macOS-Gerät.
Wow!
Fremdartige Welten.
Ich muss allerdings auch zugeben, dass es mich wirklich genervt hat,
dass ich mich mit eigentlich allen relevanten mobilen
und Desktop-Betriebssystemen einigermaßen gut auskenne,
aber halt überhaupt nicht mit macOS.
Und mein Selbstverständnis als Tech-Journalist ist schon so,
dass ich so unabhängig und neutral wie möglich sein will,
und mit diesen komischen Fanboy- und Girl-Konflikten
nichts zu tun haben will.
Und wie kann ich denn bitte wissen,
dass mir, sagen wir mal, Linux am besten gefällt,
wenn ich die Alternativen gar nicht kenne?
Also, macOS stand eh auf meiner To-Do-Liste,
auch wenn ich zugegebenermaßen ein bisschen Angst davor hatte.
Ja, und nun brauchte ich einen neuen Büro-Rechner,
ein Notebook sollte es sein,
da ich viel zwischen irgendwelchen Drehorten hin und her renne
und da gern mein Zeug dabei habe.
An meinen Hauptarbeitsplätzen wollte ich einen großen Monitor
und eine richtige Tastatur benutzen.
Und um ehrlich zu sein, hatte ich mit Windows...
Da kann er sich ja den Monitorhalter für 1.000 Euro kaufen.
...Dockingstation, häufiger mal Probleme,
irgendwelches Auflösungsgefruckel,
dass er sich das nicht richtig gemerkt hat,
wie ich das eingestellt habe.
Kennt ihr noch diesen...
diesen Monitorhalter für 1.000 Euro?
Ja, fand ich alles nicht so smooth.
Die Apple-Leute im Team schwärmten da aber immer von,
wie einfach das alles mit macOS klappt.
Was dann letztendlich den Ausschlag gegeben hat,
war eine einzige Software, Whisper von OpenAI,
die ich regelmäßig benutze,
um Texttranskriptionen unserer Videos vorzubereiten,
für die YouTube Untertitel zum Beispiel.
Da wirft man einfach eine Audiodatei drauf
und dann kommt da hinten fast veröffentlichungsfähiger Text raus.
Ja, und unter Windows und Linux läuft das nur
mit einer richtig fetten Grafikkarte
mit mindestens...
...10 GB Videospeicher.
Und außerdem habe ich noch keine richtige
grafische Benutzeroberfläche dafür gefunden.
Also alles so Kommandozeile.
Unter macOS dagegen gibt es ein super nice
zu bedienendes grafisches Tool,
das auch noch sehr schnell auf Apple-Silicon-Hardware läuft.
Entschieden habe ich mich letztendlich für ein MacBook Air
mit M2 und 24 GB RAM.
In Midnight.
Die lassen sich dort bestimmt auch
Speicherplatz wieder fürstlich bezahlen, oder?
Also dieses nette Blau-Schwarz,
das fand ich ziemlich schön.
Und das ist auch neutraler, finde ich,
als dieses Standard-Silber,
das ich irgendwie sofort mit MacBooks assoziiere.
Ja, dann los geht's.
USB-C-Kabel vom Monitor rein.
Ja, geht.
Hä, das...
Warte mal, mein Monitor hat gar keinen USB-C-Anschluss.
Dann wird vom Monitor halt direkt über Power Delivery
mit Strom versorgt.
Maus und Tastatur stecken einfach per USB im Monitor.
Ja, und dann konnte man damit arbeiten.
Ja, also ich weiß, das können aktuelle Windows-Notebooks auch.
Und das ist mit Windows 11 auch deutlich besser geworden.
Aber mit macOS funktioniert dieses ganze Docking-Station-Ding
meiner Meinung nach noch ein kleines bisschen geschmeidiger.
Was ich nun aber erst mal herausfinden musste,
wie installiert man eigentlich Software auf so einem Apple?
Das weiß ich, das weiß ich.
Okay, entweder über den App-Store oder man lädt sich einen Package runter
und track-and-droppt das Package auf so ein Installer-Icon.
Das habe ich auch schon mal gemacht.
Das ist eines meiner wenigen macOS-Erfahrungen.
Mal App-Store ausprobiert, hier unten in der Taskleiste.
Okay, da habe ich dann schon direkt mal die Whisper-Software gefunden
und installiert.
Kannst du mal ein Video machen, Windows 10 versus Windows 11?
Naja, ich habe ja schon mal ein paar Windows-11-Videos gemacht.
So viel hat sich ja da nicht getan.
Ich verwende Windows 11 ja eigentlich auch nicht,
weil ich scharf auf Windows 11 bin,
sondern weil Windows 11 das einzige OS ist,
zumindest Microsoft-Windows-mäßig,
was meine CPU ordentlich unterstützt.
Das gibt es ja nicht. Dafür gibt es Launchpad.
Das zeigt alle installierten Programme an.
Ja, okay, da ist auch Whisper.
Oder man kann auch den Finder verwenden.
Das ist quasi der Dateibrowser, aka Explorer in Windows.
Und da finden sich die installierten Programme
ja eigentlich ganz logisch im Ordner Programme.
Das benutze ich aber nicht,
sondern ich finde Spotlight viel eleganter.
Einfach die Command-Taste plus Leertaste, dann geht Spotlight auf.
Das ist sozusagen so ein kombinierter Launcher
plus geräteübergreifender Suchfunktion.
Da gebe ich dann WH ein und schon ergänzt Spotlight zu Whisper.
Das ist ganz nice.
Ich meine, ich habe ja unter Linux
was Ähnliches, wenn auch nicht optisch so hübsch
und wahrscheinlich auch nicht so gut integriert mit dem OS,
wie das unter Mac der Fall ist.
Ja, Windows kannst du komplett knicken,
was das Startmenü angeht, komplett für den Arsch.
Die Suche ist auch für den Arsch.
Noch schlimmer, dass man hier immer irgendwas eingibt,
manchmal irgendwelche komischen Web-Ergebnisse bekommt
und so was ganz painstampig.
So, ich habe ja auch hier so was zum Starten.
Guck, hier kann ich auch eins sagen,
Firefox oder Tuna für File Manager oder so was.
Also, so was hier geht auch.
Und noch besser, ich kann sogar Emojis durchsuchen.
Keckel hier. Ah, nee, gibt es da nicht.
Da habe ich hier was, was ich...
Hartz.
Dann habe ich noch meinen durchsuchbaren Clipboard-Manager
und ein paar Skripts zum Ausführen.
Ja, das finde ich auch ganz nice.
Man kann das auch kombinieren.
Ja, man könnte beispielsweise
eine Suche machen über alles hier unten drunter.
Will ich aber gar nicht.
Ich finde das eigentlich ganz gut, wenn das ein bisschen eingeschränkt ist.
Ja, also, wenn ich irgendwas Grafisches starten muss,
mache ich das eigentlich immer darüber.
Zum Beispiel, wenn ich sage, hier, ich will ein Raspberry Pi Imager.
Ja, man findet das auch so, man muss nicht Imager suchen.
Also, wenn ich Raspberry Pi Imager starten will,
kann ich das auch hier mitmachen.
Also, das finde ich ganz nice.
Das ist bei mir übrigens nicht auf Windows-Taste Space,
beziehungsweise Control-Space,
wie bei Mac, sondern ich habe es auf Windows-Taste D.
Und ich habe Windows-Taste P für Copy-Paste Clipboard-Manager.
Obwohl es eigentlich das gleiche Programm ist.
Ich kann auch dazwischen umschalten.
Also, hier, Firefox starten, geht dann halt auch so relativ schnell.
Terminal habe ich als Shortcut auf Windows-Taste Enter.
Und hier kann man z.B. Studio Code aufmachen.
Dann kann man hier rüber switchen, kann Rider aufmachen und so.
Da hat man alles.
Hier oben ist übrigens meine CPU-Auslastung.
Ich habe gerade acht Kerne voll, keck.
Ja.
Ups, was habe ich jetzt gemacht?
Jetzt habe ich das in Fullscreen geschaltet und ich weiß nicht wie.
Cool.
Ja, okay.
Was macht eigentlich die JetBrains Toolbox?
Gibt es da wieder neue Sachen?
No POS.
Check for Updates.
Keine Updates, okay.
Ja, so sieht das aus.
So, gucken wir mal weiter, wie es mit seiner macOS Journey ausschaut.
Am Start-Hit, super.
So, das über Tastatur zu bedienen, also über die Schnellsuche,
ist auch bei Windows und Linux meine favorisierte Programmstartart.
Nur, dass man halt unter Windows und oft auch unter Linux
einfach nur die Command-Taste drücken muss.
Bei macOS ist das halt Command plus Space, um diese Suche aufzurufen.
Gut, das hat sich schnell eingespeichert, dass man die Leertaste noch braucht.
Ich muss auch sagen, dass Spotlight etwas besser funktioniert
als die Suchfunktion von Windows.
Ich finde Spotlight nämlich übersichtlicher
und die findet auch relevantere Sachen für mich, also in Mail.
Ja, gut.
Ist halt komplett lost.
Was mein Rofi unter Linux nicht kann, ist tatsächlich Kontext,
also Content von Files, so kontextbasiert zu durchsuchen.
Ehrlich gesagt, keine Ahnung, ob das mir viel bringen würde.
Ist jetzt selten, dass ich mir denke, oh, hier wäre jetzt cool,
wenn ich direkt nach Dateienhalten suchen kann.
Wenn ich was suche, dann mache ich einfach Find oder Grab
auf der Kommandozeile, aber gut.
Wenn es dann um so was wie Kalendereinträge und so geht,
okay, lasse ich mir gefallen, dass das ganz cool ist.
Da kommst du mit Grab halt nicht weiter.
Angenommen, du hast irgendwie dein Thunderbird oder dein WebOutlook
oder was auch immer, dann wäre so eine Integration ganz gut.
Wobei die Integration wahrscheinlich auch nur gut funktioniert,
wenn du das macOS eigene E-Mail-Programm ...
Die haben ganz gute CalDAV-Unterstützung,
was leider unter Windows ein bisschen krankt.
Ja.
Das kann man auch nicht. Ja, na gut.
Blender, Fotos und so weiter, das ist ganz cool.
So, aber jetzt mal etwas strukturierter alles.
Hier kommen jetzt vier positive Überraschungen
und dann noch mal vier negative.
Positive Überraschung Nummer eins, Performance und Effizienz.
Das hat natürlich nicht direkt mit dem Betriebssystem zu tun,
aber ich bin wirklich von der hohen Schwubtizität meines MacBooks überrascht.
Das ist auch was ... Ich habe nicht oft was mit Mac gemacht,
aber immer, wenn ich da mal dran ...
... gegangen bin,
das hat sich äußerst responsive alles angefühlt.
Und das war noch zu Zeiten vor M2 und M1.
Ist auf dem iPad und auf dem iPhone ähnlich,
aber das ist noch mal ein anderes Level.
Also, wie gesagt, ich hatte noch Intel-basierte Macs,
wo ich ab und zu mal dran gegangen bin.
Das hat sich da auch schon alles sehr, sehr responsive angefühlt.
Arsch. Alles geht schnell.
Ich habe mir lediglich beim Berechnen von KI-Bildern mit Stable Diffusion gewünscht,
dass der Rechner ein bisschen mehr Wumms hätte.
Bei wirklich allen anderen Aufgaben kam mir die Reaktionsgeschwindigkeit
sogar schneller vor als mit meiner fetten Windows-Desktop-Maschine.
Dass das mit einem passiv gekühlten Laptop möglich ist,
hätte ich noch vor ein paar Jahren nicht für möglich gehalten.
Das Krasse dabei ist, das Ding wird nicht mal heiß und der Akku hält ewig.
Apple Silicon mit ARM-Architektur ist wirklich ein Sprung nach vorne.
Vor allem, wenn man die Leistung pro Watt betrachtet.
Ich bin wirklich gespannt, wie das weitergeht mit ARM versus Vintel x86.
Wir haben schon mal ein Video dazu gemacht. Das ist hier oben.
Positive Überraschung Nummer zwei.
Integration von iPhone und iPad.
Vermutlich sind da alle von erschreckt worden,
die zum ersten Mal macOS mit dem iPhone benutzt haben.
Wenn jemand anruft, klingelt der Computer und man erschreckt sich.
Da kommt dann so ein Pop-up oben rechts
und man kann den Anruf direkt auf dem Rechner annehmen,
auch wenn das Telefon in einem ganz anderen Raum ist.
Für mich ist das super, weil ich das Telefon meistens lautlos habe
und dann nicht mitbekomme, wenn jemand anruft, wenn ich vom Rechner sitze.
Richtig nett ist auch, dass macOS die per SMS aufs iPhone geschickten
Zwei-Faktor-Codes automatisch bereitstellt.
Wenn man auf dem iPhone Einstellungen, Nachrichten, SMS,
Weiterleitung aktiviert hat, füllt der Browser direkt beim Einloggen
auf dem Rechner den Zwei-Faktor-Code aus.
Außerdem geht es sogar copy-paste-hardwareübergreifend.
Ich kann also einen Text oder Bild auf dem Rechner kopieren.
Wobei man sich fragt, hebt man damit nicht Zwei-Faktor so ein bisschen aus?
Das muss ich mir jetzt noch mal kurz angucken.
Das ist auch das macOS,
die per SMS aufs iPhone geschickten Zwei-Faktor-Codes automatisch bereitstellt.
Wenn man auf dem iPhone Einstellungen, Nachrichten, SMS, Weiterleitung
aktiviert hat, füllt der Browser direkt beim Einloggen auf dem Rechner...
Na gut, damit hebt man aber Zwei-Faktor schon so ein bisschen aus, ne?
Weil du nicht aktiv das zweite Gerät mehr brauchst, draufgucken musst.
Ja, es als zweiten Faktor benutzt, sondern es wird halt automatisch...
Das hebt doch ein bisschen Zwei-Faktor.
Ich meine, das ist zwar...
Naja, stell dir vor, du hast dir irgendeinen Keylogger oder irgendeinen Trojaner eingefallen.
Irgendwas Remote-mäßiges.
Ja doch, stell dir vor, du hast dir irgendeinen Trojaner eingefangen auf deinem Rechner.
Gut, beim Mac ein bisschen schwieriger.
Irgendwie, du hast eine...
Machen wir es mal ganz simpel, ja?
Irgendjemand ist per Team-Viewer-Session auf deinem Rechner drauf.
Um es mal ganz simpel zu machen.
Der macht einfach deinen Browser auf.
Loggt sich da ein, weil du wahrscheinlich irgendein Passwort-Auto-Fillen drinne hast.
Dann kriegt er eine Meldung, bitte Code eingeben.
Und es wird automatisch completed vom iPhone.
Wohingegen der zweite Faktor eigentlich nicht wirklich existent war.
Der zweite Faktor wäre, du musst dein iPhone nehmen, entsperren,
draufgucken, was es für ein Code ist und eintippen.
Das könnte der Angreifer nicht machen.
Oder der, der Team-Viewer-Session-Typ nicht machen.
Es hebt schon ein bisschen Zwei-Faktor-Organisation aus.
Ja, Zwei-Faktor im Passwort safe zu haben, ist ja bescheuert.
Ne?
Das ist kein zweiter Faktor, wenn man das Shared-Secret im Passwort safe hat.
Und der Passwort safe kann ja dann auch OTP-Tokens und so generieren.
Das ist aber dann unsinnig. Das ist kein zweiter Faktor mehr.
... den Zwei-Faktor-Code aus.
Ja, aber gerade da würdest du Zwei-Faktor-Organisation brauchen,
wenn schon die Kacke am Dampfen ist.
Das weicht das ein bisschen auf, macht es natürlich deutlich bequemer.
Außerdem geht sogar copy-paste-hardware-übergreifend.
Ich kann also einen Text oder Bild auf dem Rechner kopieren
und ihn dann einfach auf dem iPhone einfügen.
Okay.
So geht das auch weiter. iPhones kann man ohne...
Aber natürlich alles nur, wenn du es mit der Cloud verbunden hast.
... iPads werden, wenn sie im gleichen Netz hängen,
von macOS automatisch als Zusatz-Display vorgeschlagen.
Im WLAN klappte das bei mir allerdings eher hakelig mit dem Zusatz-Display,
aber mit Kabel angeschlossen ging das super.
Ja, und klar, all das geht nur, wenn man voll ins Apple-Ökosystem reinspringt
und halt iPhones und iPads statt Android-Geräte nutzt.
Man kann das volle Potenzial also nur ausschöpfen, wenn man all in geht.
Cleverer Move, Apple.
Positive Überraschung Nummer drei.
Das kann Apple gut.
Jede Software, die ich brauche, gibt es.
Ja, wirklich alles, was sich so in Jahrzehnten an Software
für meinen Arbeitsalltag angesammelt hat,
konnte ich problemlos unter macOS nutzen.
Und das ohne irgendwelche Umgewöhnungen.
Also WireGuard, Audacity, Signal, Teams, Dropbox, Firefox, Thunderbird, Photoshop etc.
Auch so etwas seltsamere Sachen wie die Steuerungssoftware
für mein Studio-Licht habe ich sofort gefunden.
Die einzigen Kleinigkeiten, KeyPass, also das Passwort-Tool, und Qubittorrent
fand ich unter macOS etwas schlechter.
Sicherlich nur, um Linux-Distributionen runterzuladen.
Anders als unter Windows.
Aber dafür gibt es dann halt schöne macOS etwas schlechter
beziehungsweise anders als unter Windows.
Aber dafür gibt es dann halt schöne macOS-Software,
die es für Windows nicht gibt.
Wie zum Beispiel die grafische Benutzeroberfläche für Whisper.
Positive Überraschung Nummer vier.
Die Menüleiste oben.
Wie bei Windows ist die Leiste mit den Programm-Icons unten.
Aber anders als bei Windows...
Ja, ich finde das System mit der Leiste oben für quasi die Menüs so ein bisschen,
von den Anwendungen und der Leistung.
Ich finde das eigentlich eine ganz coole Sache.
Ich mochte das früher auch unter Linux.
Zu Gnome-2-Zeiten gab es das nämlich noch.
Und ich fand das eigentlich immer ganz cool.
Natürlich kann man sagen, ja, man hat ja mehr...
also so mehr horizontalen Platz als vertikalen Platz.
Dementsprechend ist das halt doof,
wenn es hier oben und unten ein bisschen was wegnimmt.
Ich fand das aber eigentlich usability-technisch ganz nice.
Es gibt es bei macOS oben noch
die sogenannte Menüleiste.
Die zeigt dann links oldschool die Menüs des gerade aktiven Programms an.
Aber rechts ist noch so etwas wie der Info-Bereich,
der bei Windows unten rechts ist.
Also zum Beispiel Uhrzeit und Datum.
Aber halt auch WLAN, Bluetooth etc.
Wie bei Windows.
Was aber nicer ist als bei Windows.
Ich sehe da oben zum Beispiel direkt, ob WireGuard gerade aktiv ist oder nicht.
Wenn nicht, ist es ausgegraut, sonst schwarz.
Bei Windows muss ich WireGuard erst anklicken.
Okay, das ist eine Kleinigkeit, aber erleichtert mir definitiv die tägliche Arbeit.
Es ist auch mehr Platz.
Es ist mehr Platz für die ganzen Quick-Icons da oben rechts bei macOS.
Bei Windows ist das erst mal per Default verkleinert,
weil es sich eben den Platz mit der Task-Leiste unten teilt.
Oben bei macOS ist mehr Platz.
So, jetzt das Negative.
Negative Überraschung Nummer eins.
Ganz ehrlich, mich macht das Fenstermanagement von macOS wahnsinnig.
Verstehe ich. Verstehe ich komplett.
Vor allem als jemand, der Tiling-Window-Manager mag,
finde ich es auch immer grausam.
Und ich mag auch diese Animationen an allen Ecken nicht,
auch unter macOS, auch wenn man das sicherlich ausschalten kann.
Ich bin bei Windows dran gewöhnt,
dass ich einfach unten rechts auf dieses kleine Feld hier klicke
und dann werden alle Fenster minimiert.
Oder Windows-D.
Wenn ich dann wieder zu einem Programm zurück will,
drücke ich Alt-Tab und cycle da so durch,
bis das gewünschte Programm wieder aufgeht.
Das geht bei macOS so nicht.
Ich kann natürlich Fenster minimieren.
Ah ja, es gibt jetzt... Moment, Alt-Tab?
Warum gibt es eigentlich Windows-Tab und Alt-Tab?
Was ist da der Sinn von? Warum gibt es nicht einfach das Gleiche zweimal?
Aber wenn ich dann mit Command-Tab da wieder hin will...
Wollen wir mal nicht so hinterfragen.
...dann geht das nicht.
In der Programmanzeige werden minimierte Programme zwar angezeigt,
aber es passiert nichts, wenn ich da draufgehe.
Außerdem funktioniert diese Snap-Funktion nicht,
die ich bei Windows lieben gelernt habe.
Einfach ein Fenster an die Seite und zack,
wird das fein säuberlich auf eine Bildschirmhälfte hochgezogen.
Bei macOS kann man länger auf dieses grüne Icon hier klicken
und ein Fenster auf linker Bildschirmseite anordnen.
Aber das ist umständlicher.
Und außerdem kann Windows auch vier oder sogar sechs teilen.
Das geht mit macOS mit Bordmitteln nicht.
Allerdings gibt es dafür Zusatzsoftware für macOS fürs Snappen,
zum Beispiel Magnet, Rectangle oder Beta-Snap-Tool.
Letzteres benutze ich, das kommt aus Deutschland und macht, was es soll.
Kostet aber alles ein paar Euro.
Umsonst und umsourced ist Alt-Tab.
Das versucht, könnt ihr euch bei dem Namen schon denken,
das Alt-Tab-Verhalten von Windows nachzubilden.
Generell ist es aber am Ende eines Arbeitstags grundsätzlich so,
dass mein macOS-Desktop vollgepflastert ist mit offenen Programmen.
Ich mag diese Animation nicht.
Es sieht zwar cool aus, aber mich nervt es.
Ich will klicken und es soll sofort was passieren.
Ich gehe aber davon aus, dass man diese Animation ausschalten kann.
... mit offenen Programmfenstern.
Und das nervt mich irgendwie ein bisschen.
Negative Überraschung Nummer zwei.
Kann macOS wobbly Windows?
Das wäre für mich ja sogar noch ein Vorteil,
mal Mac mir da mehr anzugucken.
Gibt es wobbly Windows?
Aha, Jello.
Oh, beste.
Jawoll, das ist das erste, was ich unter Mac installieren würde.
Wobbly Windows.
Einfach das Geilste, was sie je erfunden haben.
Leider wird Compits auch nicht mehr weiterentwickelt.
RAM-Installationen sind irgendwie nicht so gut.
Lädt man Software aus dem Netz, ist die Installation erst mal angenehm simpel.
Meist handelt sich das um sogenannte DMG-Distributives.
Man track-und-droppt das auf so einen Installer.
Dann sieht man so was.
Dann kann man einfach reinziehen, das Icon.
Dann kann man einfach das Programm in den Programme-Ordner ziehen.
Und das war's.
Aktiviert man die Anzeige aller Dateiendungen,
das geht im Finder unter Einstellungen erweitert,
sieht man, dass Programme einfach wirklich .app-Dateien sind.
Die klickt man an und dann starten die.
Ja, nice.
Zum Deinstallieren dann einfach die .app-Datei auf den Papierkorb
und fertig.
Oder doch nicht fertig?
Denn es gibt auf der Platte noch einen Ordner namens Library.
Und da sind etliche Dateien drin.
Viele installierte Programme legen da auch was rein.
Irgendwelche Konfigurationsdateien oder Bibliotheken oder sonst was.
Unter anderem hier ein Application Support.
Da sind z.B. Sachen von Audacity drin.
36 MB, obwohl ich das Programm gerade gelöscht habe.
Die müsste man eigentlich manuell löschen.
Aber dafür muss man das ganze Zeug erst mal finden,
was bei den ganzen Ordnern hier ziemlich umständlich ist.
Einige Programme wie die von Adobe bringen ein eigenes Uninstall-Tool mit.
Das löscht hoffentlich alles.
Aber wenn man ansonsten das System sauberhalten will,
braucht man Zusatztools.
Und das erinnert mich
an längst vergangene Windows-Zeiten.
Denn inzwischen ist sowas dort nicht mehr nötig.
Denn Windows hat ein eingebautes Tool,
das Programme ziemlich rückstandsfrei entfernt.
Die optionalen macOS-Säuberungstools
machen zwar vermutlich meist, was sie sollen,
aber man findet im Netz auch viele Menschen,
die sich damit ihr System kaputtgemacht haben.
Also das müsste doch besser gehen mit Bordmitteln, Apple, oder?
Zumindest Software, die man über den App Store installiert,
die kriegt man einigermaßen rückstandsfrei deinstalliert.
Automatisch.
Vermutlich ist das auch so ein kleiner Schubs von Apple,
um die Leute so Richtung App Store zu schieben.
Macht mal gefällig App Store.
Aber ich hab da mal drauf geachtet,
bei der Software, die ich installieren wollte,
hab ich nur so circa ein Drittel im App Store gefunden.
Die anderen Sachen hab ich noch mal aus dem Netz ziehen müssen.
Ja, wahrscheinlich, weil die keinen Bock haben,
Geld an Apple zu bezahlen.
Und allgemein ist es natürlich auch wichtig,
dass man Software außerhalb der App Stores installieren kann,
weil in den App Stores kontrolliert Apple ja,
was sie da drin haben.
Und ja, das will man natürlich bei seinem eigenen Computer nicht.
Da will man selbst die Kontrolle drüber haben,
was man da installieren darf.
Ja, Negativpunkt 3.
Warum muss Apple alles anders machen?
Ja, es gibt ja eigentlich einen Tastaturstandard,
an den sich eigentlich alle halten.
Also alle außer Apple.
Okay, Apple Computer gab es schon vor dem IBM-PC,
der 1981 rauskam und der denen de facto Tastaturstandard vorgibt.
Gut, gut, gut, gut.
Aber das Add-Zeichen für E-Mail-Adressen,
der ist bei US-Keyboards sowohl bei PCs als auch bei Apple
unter Shift-2 zu finden.
Auf deutschen PC-Tastaturen kriegt man den mit Alt-Q.
Aber bei Apple,
warum auch immer, mit Alt-L.
Und wenn man bei Apple Alt-Q drückt, dann schließt sich das.
Das kann man bestimmt ummappen, oder?
Das wäre auch eine der ersten Sachen, die ich ummappen würde.
Das aktuelle Programm.
Ja, das ist scheiße, wenn du Q drückst und es schließt das Programm,
obwohl du gerade ein Add machen wolltest.
Machen die doch extra, oder?
Also der Vorteil ist natürlich,
dass sich das Alt-L für Add sofort in mein Hirn eingebrannt hat,
weil ich will ja nicht ständig Programme schließen.
Dafür vertippe ich mich dann halt grundsätzlich,
wenn ich mal wieder auf Windows
oder Linux-Rechner unterwegs bin.
Ja, warum? Warum muss man das so machen?
Richtig seltsam finde ich auch,
dass mein MacBook keine Entfernen-Taste hat.
Die benutze ich oft, aber auf der MacBook-Tastatur
muss ich dafür Fn-Backspace drücken,
weil es eben keine extra Taste dafür gibt.
Super nervig.
Glücklicherweise benutze ich zum Arbeiten meist eine externe Tastatur.
Da erkennt macOS zumindest die dedizierte Entfernen-Taste.
Aber hier jetzt noch mal was Doofes.
Copy-Paste ist nicht Control-CV wie beim PC, sondern Command-CV.
Obwohl Apple dafür ja auch einfach die an gleicher Stelle angeordnete Fn-Taste
plus C und V hätte nutzen können,
dann würde der Unterschied gar nicht auffallen.
Nee, es muss die Command-Taste sein.
Die ist direkt neben der Leertaste.
Warum muss das anders sein? Why?
Negativpunkt 4, Kleinkraft.
Moritz, danke für den Sub.
40 Monate, das ist ja extrem hyper-Sub hier.
Nice, n-n-nice.
Danke für den Sub.
Chrome auf Mac hat sogar einen Close-by-Accident-Guard eingebaut.
Ja, verständlich.
Was mich wirklich extrem irritiert hat,
ich wollte mal schauen, wie viel Platz ich noch auf der SSD habe.
Und dann bin ich halt logisch auf Speicher in die Systemeinstellung gegangen.
Okay, 382 GB frei.
Und irgendwann später habe ich dann aber zufällig
das Festplatten-Dienstprogramm gefunden.
Und da hieß es dann 280 GB frei.
Das sind über 100 GB Unterschied.
Ist das eine Mebibyte und das andere Megabyte, oder was ist das?
Und ja...
Gartenkralle.
Danke schon für den Sub.
Makishi, 7 Monate, POG-Subscription, danke, Leute.
Oh, der Scam-Train ist am Start, Leute.
Bezos muss ins Wälder.
Sogar wenn ich beide Programme gleichzeitig starte
und die Fenster direkt nebeneinander schiebe,
zeigen sie diese sehr unterschiedlichen Werte an.
Soll das so sein?
Außerdem fand ich es seltsam, wenn man mehrere Dateien markiert
und dann mit Rechtsklick auf Informationen geht,
um zu gucken, wie viel Platz die Dateien einnehmen,
also das mache ich öfter mal unter Windows,
also wie viel Platz die zusammen einnehmen,
dann öffnet macOS für jede Datei einfach so ein kleines Fenster.
Ist das so gedacht? Ist das so richtig?
Ich könnte jetzt auch noch mit der komplett verwirrenden Foto-Verwaltung,
mit dem Fotos-Programm anfangen und der Unmöglichkeit,
Fotos vom iPhone einfach als JPEGs in den Ordner zu kopieren,
aber ich glaube, dazu könnte man eigentlich mal ein ganzes Video machen,
also wenn euch das interessiert.
Mein Fazit.
Trotz der Negativpunkte bin ich insgesamt wirklich positiv überrascht.
Ich hatte gedacht, dass ich das MacBook langfristig nur so
als Zweitrechner verwenden will, aber ich muss sagen,
mir macht das so viel Spaß, dass ich meinen PC mit Windows und Linux
in den letzten Monaten nur ein- oder zweimal eingeschaltet habe
und das auch nur für Spiele.
Also ich muss mich an einiges bei macOS wirklich noch gewöhnen,
aber die hohe Schwubtizität und dass halt wirklich vieles sehr elegant funktioniert,
ja, das ist schon alles sehr, sehr schön.
Ich will mich demnächst zwar wieder zwingen,
ein anderes Betriebssystem zu nutzen, aber womöglich mache ich das sogar auf MacBook,
denn da kommt bald Asahi Linux Reboot,
da kommt das Remix raus und das funktioniert hoffentlich besser
als die bisherigen Asahi-Linux-Versionen.
Oh, da gibt's Linux auf Mac, da.
Und für Apple Silicon Macs.
Bin da sehr gespannt drauf, vor allem, wie gut Spiele drauflaufen, genau.
Und abonnieren nicht vergessen.
Und Newsletter, und Newsletter, Newsletter abonnieren.
Bisschen Sellout muss sein.
I really feel like...
Wow, wow, wow, wow, wow.
Also, krach.
Das könnte ohne Scheiß, das könnte sein, dass sie das dabei rechnen, den Cloud-Speicher.
Das würde, das war noch ziemlich genau 100 Gigabyte, was der mehr hatte, gell?
Das würde ich auch Apple zutrauen,
dass sie das einfach mal zum Festplatten-Speicher dazurechnen, so random.
So, oh, oh, iCloud-Speicher ist halt einfach Disk-Space, jo.
Das würde zu Apple passen, das ist auch so was,
manches ist da echt ein bisschen Magic undurchsichtig.
So, und was hat das denn jetzt mit dem Pizza-Button auf sich?
26 Minuten kann ich mir jetzt nicht angucken.
Scrollen wir mal vor zum Pizza-Button.
RealPlayer, kann sich noch jemand dran erinnern?
RealPlayer, das war in Zeiten vor VLC.
Ach, der Pizza-Key funktioniert anscheinend nicht mehr.
Ey, das müssen wir nicht angucken.
Kennt noch jemand RealPlayer?
Weiß gar nicht, gibt's das noch?
Ich trau mich gar nicht mehr, das unter Windows aufzumachen.
Wer weiß, wo man da rauskommt, ob's die Website überhaupt noch gibt.
Ich mach das, ich mach das mal unter, ich mach das mal unter, unter Linux auf, hier.
RealPlayer.
Okay, das sieht jetzt moderner aus, aber die Frage ist halt,
warum sollte man das in der heutigen Zeit überhaupt noch verwenden?
Früher war das halt eines der wenigen Player,
der manche etwas exotischere Formate abspielen konnte.
Jetzt ist halt die Frage so, warum?
Ja, best PC Player ever.
Also, früher sah das Ding so aus, falls das noch jemand kennt.
Ja, so, so, oder so, genau, so sah das aus.
So sah das früher aus.
Gab's noch so, oder es gab noch Skins, genau.
Gab es nicht auch mal so was wie RealPlayer Lite?
Naja.
RealPlayer One hieß das so, kann das sein, One?
Nee, das war Ready Player One.
Ja, diese scharfe, also Winamp hatte das Lama.
Ob RealPlayer scharfer hat, weiß ich nicht.
Ja, ich hab damals, das weiß ich noch, mit, mit RealPlayer,
damals hatten die Ärzte bei T-Online gestreamt,
so testweise mal, das war so eines der ersten Übertragungsstreams,
die ich geguckt hab, das ging irgendwie, keine Ahnung,
so eine Stunde und das konnte man sich nur angucken mit RealPlayer
und dann war das auch, dann war das auch halt nur irgendwie in 240p
und megaschlechter Qualität.
Aber man, man hatte so den Eindruck, Alter, die Zukunft ist jetzt,
Streaming übers Internet.
Ja, wir werden nicht alt, ich bin schon alt, ich bin jetzt 39, Leute,
kann man sich kaum vorstellen.
Ich komm ja auch nicht so vor, aber es ist so.
Unifies biggest mistake, okay, vier Minuten.
Jemand von euch noch Unify am Start?
Ich hab hier mein Unify ausgemustert vor so eineinhalb Jahren.
In dem Video geht's um die Kameras.
Okay, dann will ich das nicht gucken, wenn's um Kameras geht.
Because I'm doing my own writing.
But to give a little context, let's go back to the beginning.
About ten years ago we started to put Unifys on offices.
We really liked this of UNIFY video
or either, a, they could, really like their networking equipment.
As a matter of fact, their access points,
I feel like, are probably the gold standard in our...
Wie gesagt, ich hab die access points rausgeschmissen
und ich hab kein Uniws mehr am Start.
...our industry.
So that's actually made up for some of the shortcomings
that we've had with some of their other products.
As a matter of fact,
switch back to using protect in dozens of our kameras interessieren mich jetzt
weniger okay es geht wirklich um kamera shit ja wie nirgends denn i just quit
my job was ja schön für ihn ja also ich habe univer ausgeschmissen
bei mir was wifi angeht kameras hatte ich von denen die großartig im einsatz
eine habe ich mal eine eine habe ich gekauft die habe ich auch habe ich die
habe ich nirgends vor im einsatz gerade also seitdem ich seitdem ich die univer
access points hier raus hat muss ich sagen ist das gesamte wlan qualität auch
empfangen auf der terrasse und und dem hof und so ist deutlich besser geworden
und ich habe ja damals auch schon nicht die neuesten access points mehr gekauft
ich habe mir damals gebrauchte auf ebay gekauft was ich jetzt habe ich habe
ruckus ruckus ist wahrscheinlich die arbeit ruckus habe ich jetzt da kostet
halt ein access point auch einfach drei bis vier mal so viel wie in den univer
access point ruckus habe ich was habe ich werde ich deswegen habe ich die auch
ihr auf ebay gekauft deswegen habe ich die dinge auch ebay auf ebay gekauft
also ich habe ich habe mir bei ebay ruckus er 710 habe ich mir gekauft mit
200 euro ja so in dem dreh ja sowas sowas hier habe ich entfesselt sowieso
krempel habe ich hier gekauft muss man halt mal schauen
also wenn man glück hat gibt es halt gerade welche in deutschland und
ansonsten muss man es also gibt es immer mal wieder gebrauchte immer wieder
gebrauchen so im dreh um 200 euro da man muss bei einer sache aufpassen wenn das
ein us access point ist also hier us 00 dann kann man den nicht in deutschland
betreiben es sei denn man stellt die region um
die region kann man offiziell nicht umstellen weil kona sicherheitsstandard
network network security equipment dafür nur unter bestimmten auflagen exportiert
werden blablabla das heißt sie haben das in der firma gelockt aber es gibt auf
github eine anleitung wie man einen us access point in einen internationalen
access point um moddet und das ist mega einfach hier ruckus us und unlock gibt's auf
ruckus us access point gibt's auf
ruckus us access point gibt's auf github irgendwo das da könnte sogar
github irgendwo das da könnte sogar
github irgendwo das da könnte sogar sein
sein
sein change the country code genau das muss
change the country code genau das muss
change the country code genau das muss man machen das ist eigentlich total easy
man machen das ist eigentlich total easy
man machen das ist eigentlich total easy postleitzahl liegt oh mein gott
postleitzahl liegt oh mein gott
postleitzahl liegt oh mein gott oh nein wie wurde
oh nein wie wurde
oh nein wie wurde wo habe ich bei google oder was oder bei
wo habe ich bei google oder was oder bei
wo habe ich bei google oder was oder bei ebay wo habe ich postleitzahl geliebt
ebay wo habe ich postleitzahl geliebt
Bei Ebay. Ja, bei der Ebay-Suche hier oben, ne?
Ja, ja, ja. Ich wohne ja auch
im Main, wisst ihr ja auch, mitten im Main.
So, hier gibt es eine Anleitung,
wie man das macht.
Man muss downgraden auf eine
ältere Firmware, das ist aber kein Problem, das funktioniert.
Und danach muss man sich
per SSH auf dem Access Point einloggen
und ein paar Befehle eingeben.
Also, ist nicht schwer und dann
kann man auch einen US-Access Point
in einen internationalen Access Point
ummodden. Und ich muss sagen,
das sind nicht die neuesten Access Points gewesen.
Ich meine, Ebay, ja.
Und sicherlich auch nicht
die aller, aller schnellsten.
Das ist die zweite Generation
von den
Access Points, die
Wi-Fi 5 ist es, glaube ich,
unterstützen. Also
IEEE
802.11ax
oder so.
Aber es ist schnell genug.
Und die haben sehr viele Features, die ich
mega finde. Auch
ein Killer-Feature schlechthin,
was ich bei UniFi immer vermisst habe,
nämlich individuelle Gerätepasswörter,
was UniFi halt
einfach nicht hinbekommt.
Und auch diese Technik, mit der sich
die Antennen richtig auf die Geräte ausrichten
und so. Ist nice. Also ich bin
damit sehr zufrieden.
Und ich würde mir auch
eine neue Generation kaufen.
Aber nicht neu, sondern auch wieder auf
Ebay. Also mal gucken, wie es
700 Optionen gebrauchte 750
gibt. Weil neu,
sind diese Access Points doch ein bisschen
teuer.
1.130 Euro.
Ich meine, irgendwo
ist ja auch mal gut.
Was hat dein Gigabit-Internet mit deinem
WLAN zu tun? Kann auch sein.
Also die sind
schon ein bisschen
teurer. Ich werde
warten, bis ein bisschen Zeit ins Land
gegangen ist und man die Generation
günstiger bekommt.
Solange benutze ich
mal 710 und 610 noch weiter.
Nee.
510 und 710.
In R350,
die Kleinen haben oftmals ein Problem,
dass sie nicht mehr so lange supported werden.
Also ich würde nur 506 oder 700 annehmen.
Achso, ja. Gut.
Ja, solange man keine Probleme hat.
Also ich wollte halt
bei Unify ein Feature haben,
was viele andere Anbieter schon lange haben,
aber Unify es nicht geschissen bekommt.
Und das sind individuelle WLAN-Passwörter
für Geräte.
Also sprich,
dass mein
...
... iPhone ein anderes WLAN-Passwort bekommt
wie mein Tablet,
dass mein
...
... Raspberry Pi ein anderes WLAN-Passwort bekommt
wie ein ESP32 und sowas.
Das können
die, diese Ruckus-Dinger schon ewig
und Unify bekommt es.
Äh, OpenWRT kann es
by the way auch,
aber MikroTik kann es auch,
Cisco kann es auch,
aber Unify bekommt es einfach nicht hin.
Warum nicht einfach Radius?
Ja, weil sehr viele Geräte kein
... äh, äh, WPA-Enterprise unterstützen.
Okay, Unify, Unify bekommt es einfach nicht hin, ne?
Gibt ja sogar schon hier Fragen.
Ankündigung weiterlesen.
Oh, Moment!
Gibt es das jetzt mittlerweile?
What?
Nee.
Das, das haben wir doch schon mal gesehen,
diese, das stimmt doch überhaupt nicht,
was, was der Typ hier schreibt.
Requested for ages, genau.
Wird das.
Requested for ages.
Und Unify hat einfach keinen Bock da drauf.
Ja.
Schade.
Das wäre nämlich wirklich ein Mega-Mega-Feature
für alle Leute, die auch ein paar IoT-Geräte haben
und die halt eben keinen WPA-Enterprise können.
Das ist halt das Ding.
Versuch mal,
versuch mal bei irgendeinem, bei einem 0815-WiFi-Klübier, ne,
WPA-Enterprise mit Radius zu machen.
Du wirst es halt nicht hinbekommen, weil die das nicht unterstützen.
Ich muss mal kurz gucken,
ob es noch neue Firmware gibt.
Firmware.
Wann gab es denn neue Firmware?
Firmware hierzu.
Joseph Product, R710.
Also die Seite von denen ist auch wirklich absolut hyper-pepega, Mann.
Das ist das Falsche doch.
Downloads.
Vierter, siebter.
Ich glaube, das habe ich schon geupdatet.
Ne, Moment.
Unleashed brauchen wir.
Kam raus am 28.06.
Ja, ich glaube, das, glaube, das habe ich schon.
Release Notes.
Man darf das, glaube ich, nicht runterladen ohne Account.
Ja, ja.
WLAN nur für dieses eine Gerät.
Ja, geil.
Top.
Übrigens bringt dir das trotzdem nichts.
Das WLAN-Passwort ist immer noch das Gleiche.
Du willst ja dein WLAN-Passwort nicht unbedingt in den Müll schmeißen.
Und für jedes eigene Gerät in der SSID ist auch bescheuert.
Also das ist wirklich ein sehr sinnvolles Feature.
Und dementsprechend unterstützen das auch alle Hersteller außer Unifile.
Weil überlegt euch mal.
Angenommen, ihr habt eine WLAN-Klübier, ne?
Hängt bei euch im WLAN-Klub.
Dann habt ihr eine WLAN-Klübier.
Hängt bei euch im WLAN.
Ihr schmeißt die Klübirne weg.
Vielleicht, weil sie nicht mehr geht.
Dann legt euer WLAN-Passwort in den Müll.
Die Chancen, dass jetzt jemand hinkommt, euer WLAN-Passwort daraus extrahiert, ist relativ gering.
Aber doch mit mehr oder weniger vertretbarem Aufwand möglich.
Und will man wirklich sein WLAN-Passwort in den Müll schmeißen?
Das ist genauso wie unverschlüsselte Festplatten in den Müll schmeißen.
Das ist ja auch der Grund, warum ich immer sage.
Einfach die Festplatte defaultmäßig verschlüsseln.
Dann kann sie nämlich, wenn sie kaputt geht, einfach in den Müll geschmissen werden.
Und gut ist.
Mach mal ein ESP32 so kaputt, dass du in den Speicher nicht mehr drankommst.
Das ist gar nicht so einfach.
Die Dinger haben Metallgehäuse.
Da bräuchtest du einen Schredder.
Und Schredder, der Metall schreddert?
Ja.
Ja, aber das Beste ist, wenn es per Design gar nicht geht.
Wisst ihr?
Man kann immer workaround Bitlocker.
Nein, Veracrypt.
Man kann immer workarounden mit irgendwas.
Aber am besten ist, wenn das Verfahren dahinter sicher ist.
Und wenn du pro Gerät ein Passwort vergeben kannst.
Und das Gerät dann einfach entfernst.
Dann kann das Passwort im Müll liegen.
Und das bringt nichts mehr.
Also das war eines der Gründe, warum ich gesagt habe.
Wäre nice.
Und ich hatte mit Unify auch Empfangsprobleme auf der Terrasse.
Das hat irgendwie immer rumgebackt.
Seitdem ich diese zwei Ruckus Access Points habe.
Habe eins hier im ersten Stock.
Eins unten im Keller.
Alles gut.
Komplett über die Straße rüber sogar noch empfangen.
Das ist top.
So, Leute.
Ich habe Hunger.
Ich gehe jetzt was essen.
Pepo Fat Time.
Nudel mit Lachs.
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Wahrscheinlich schon.
Mal gucken.
Bis dann, Leute.
Macht's gut.
Vielleicht, höchstwahrscheinlich sogar, basteln wir heute Mittag Frontend-Sweltge-Zeug weiter.
Sweltge.
Wenn euch die Streams gefallen, freue ich mich über ein Follow.
Und wir sehen uns.
Bis dann.
Macht's gut.
See you.